[Music]
Senator Michael Bennet of Colorado has
served in the US Senate since 2009 he
has also been one of the Democrats
considering a run for president in 2020
senator Bennet joins us now only on CBS
this morning to announce his plans for
the future good morning senator morning
so what are your plans you know my plan
is to run for president I appreciate
your letting me come here to announce
that I think this country faces two
enormous challenges among others one is
a lack of economic mobility and
opportunity for most Americans and the
other is the need to restore integrity
to our government I need I think we need
to do both of those things and I've
spent the last couple of years writing a
book about our politics over the last 10
years or so and I became convinced in
that process that if we continue to go
down the path we're going and this isn't
just about President Trump it's about
the politics that existed before he got
there he certainly has made matters
worse but if we keep going down this
road we're gonna be the first generation
of Americans to leave less opportunity
not more to the next generation and I I
just need to do everything I can do to
make sure that we don't do that you
recently got a prostate cancer diagnosis
and you said that made you want to do
bigger things is this decision a part of
that it was it was very clarifying you
know I I feel incredibly lucky because I
got a diagnosis in five years later
after an operation I was cleared with a
clean bill of health
that gave me a chance to think about
whether I really wanted to run or not
and in the in the context of getting the
diagnosis
my reaction was which disappointment at
the idea I couldn't run it would have
been a great excuse to say this is just
some adolescent fantasy and I shouldn't
run that's not how I reacted and frankly
the other reaction I had was to think
about what it would feel like to get a
diagnosis like that and to not have
insurance and to know that this
president has worked so hard since he's
been president to take insurance away
from people in America let me quick
political question before we go back to
Paula - but before we go back to policy
there are 20 some-odd candidates that we
don't can't even fix on a proper number
you're not
you're not the only person from Colorado
who's running right so John Hickenlooper
running as well for whom you used to
work so in the in the business of
politics how do you distinguish yourself
from all the other well you know what I
called my mom and I said to her somebody
has to be 22 and that's why I'm running
and it turns out I'm not I'm 21 so I've
already made a little bit of progress I
think I distinguish myself in a number
of ways one is I have a tendency to tell
the truth the people I represent in
Colorado and want the chance to do that
with the American people
second I've won very tough races in a
purple state winning red counties in
that state and third I've got a track
record of bipartisan work that's been
harder to do during the Trump
administration but still over the 10
years that I've been in the Senate and
then before that a track record in
business turning around failing
businesses and working for five years
for the children in the Denver Public
Schools as their superintendent I don't
think anybody has his broadest set of
experiences in the field and I think
that will distinguish me let me ask you
you want to focus on health care but you
talk about bipartisan working in washing
there are a lot of Democrats who think
that bipartisanship doesn't exist in
Washington anymore yeah that the
candidate who's the nominee of the party
has to participate in politics as they
are not as they should be in some dream
about bipartisanship that doesn't exist
yeah I think that's even more naive than
then believing in some dream that
doesn't exist in other words it's naive
when you're at when you're when you're
considering whether you're gonna deliver
for the next generation of Americans
there is no bipartisanship in Washington
today to speak up that is true and we
have been terrorized for the last ten
years by the freedom caucus these people
won't cooperate they won't compromise
they believe they have a monopoly on
wisdom and they've got a cartoon version
of what the Founding Fathers were trying
to do they need to be beaten or they
need to be closed over but I come from
and they and I come from a state that's
1/3 Democratic 1/3 independent and a
third Republican the people I work with
are not like the freedom caucus they are
Americans who are trying to drive
opportunity for their families and for
the next generation and they need a
politics that recognizes that they have
disagreements among themselves but they
have a shared there's
desire to move the country forward we
have drained our politics of that in
Washington our politics in Washington
lack all imagination and I think going
down the rat hole with the people that
are dragging us down the rat hole just
as a self-fulfilling prophecy of failing
as a republic that's what I really
believe that's what I think is at stake
given the number of Democrats that are
running for president is that a sign of
a healthy party or a party who doesn't
know what it what it really well I think
it's both I think I think the Democratic
right now the Democratic Party doesn't
stand for very much at the national
level with respect to what the American
people think but this is the opportunity
for us to show what we stand for for us
to have a competition of ideas and I
think it's phenomenal that we've got as
diverse array of candidates as we have
in all respects and that we've got the
number that we have you know we it's a
process like this is long overdue in the
Democratic Party what's the other big
policy idea there should be a
competition about well I think another
welcome in health care well to me it's
economic mobility how do we restore an
economy where when but the president
would say the economy is doing great
yeah he would say that let me say a
couple things about that first of all if
you look at a chart of the jobs created
since onine which is that the depths of
the recession when Barack Obama took
over until today the chart goes like
this every single every single year it's
gone like this president Trump's been
present since here so I will give him
credit for not screwing up what was
already happening before he got there
but from the vantage point of people in
our country who can't afford housing
can't afford health care can't afford
early childhood education can't afford
higher education can't afford a
middle-class life they need us to
restore economic mobility in this
country and that is what we should be
focused on in this campaign all right
we're gonna have to leave it there
thanks for being with us he's running